foreign
well hello there you are watching The
Press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages time then to see what is
making the headlines with the political
editor of the Daily Mirror paper carera
and the home Affairs editor at the Times
Matt datham both of them with us from
now until just before midnight and
welcome to both of you from Pages then
let's have a look shall we and with
temperatures forecast to hit or exceed
40 degrees celsius on Tuesday the Metro
warns get ready for the hottest day ever
here's how the telegraph sums up the
situation record highs travel chaos
schools close and it's going to get
hotter
The Sun Also leads with the heat wave
stating that Britain is melting
the eye takes a wider view highlighting
the overall impact on the climate the
headline Earth sends a warning the
guardian points out that Boris Johnson
missed an emergency meeting about the
Heat
the star shows a police officer helping
one of the Queen's guards to take a
drink of water quipping and you thought
you were having a bad day
the times focuses on the conservative
leadership battle saying that the race
to be prime minister has been thrown
wide open
The Daily Mail centers on what it says
is Penny morden's stagnating leadership
bid claiming that her campaign has hit
the buffers and the financial times has
a story concerning the chip maker arm
well reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch the program so let's return then
to pibokira and Matt datham Matt I don't
know how hot it is at home thank you for
joining us as the temperatures remain 26
degrees or so overnight but many of the
newspapers leading on this including the
Daily Telegraph record highs travel
chaos schools close and uh you know wait
for Tuesday I guess
oh yeah that's right if we people
thought today was hot then then tomorrow
it's not just going to be hotter but
considerably hotter and uh some uh some
met uh forecasters are saying it could
even reach 40 43 degrees which would be
quite incredible and there's a 95 chance
that the telegraph says on its front
page of us beating that uh record that
set back in 2019 uh today it reached a
record of I think it was at 38.1 degrees
in in Suffolk um and I think it could
actually be hotter in the northern
England than actually in London which um
is surprised some because we were all
told that London was going to because it
was going to reach those 40 levels
tomorrow yes indeed and the sort of the
urban heat island effect is what we've
heard a lot about that it retains heat
in urban centers making it very
difficult for people often who don't
have Gardens I guess as well to to
escape some of it although we're all
told to stay indoors which is not always
easy
um the sun there as well Pippa Britain
is melting and lots of questions today
about you know how ready we are to deal
with with temperatures like this the
fact this could be the new normal and
you see places like Luton Airport you
know the the tarmac in in real trouble
including other roads as well elsewhere
yeah the suggestion is is that we're
likely to see uh more temperatures high
temperatures like this in the coming
years than we have in the past people
like to hark back to the heat wave of
1976 but
um where there was a couple of weeks the
summer of 76 where temperatures were in
the low 30s but it it was just a
different order of magnitude from the
from the high 30s and potentially 40
degree plus that we're that we're seeing
at the moment
um and Britain isn't I mean the thing
about us and we see this in the winter
when when it snows heavily is that we're
actually quite a mod we're actually
quite a moderate climate
um and we can't cope with extremists
very well mainly because this is the
pressure isn't there for the sake of a
few days a year to invest in
infrastructure that can withstand with
extreme heat and extreme colds and we're
seeing it with the probably more used to
the extreme cold but we're seeing it
with the extreme heat at the moment and
not just Luton but are Bryce Norton as
well they had to cancel the flights
taking off because of
um tarmac on the runway getting sticky
and therefore being unsafe we saw roads
around London out on the outskirts of
London being shot down as well for
similar reason there was some tracks
train tracks buckling Vauxhall in London
was one example but there are others
across the country and that's before you
even get started on whether operations
for example can take place in operating
theaters and hospitals which are deem
too hot or whether it's safe for
children to be at school with obviously
into their conditioning in our schools
um for the most part so while the vast
majority of people who've got pictures
there of somebody at sunbathing or the
Boston judge people will be you know it
would have been
um taking precautions but maybe enjoying
the warmth um drinking lots of water
staying inside if they're outside
hopefully the sun cream on there are of
course extreme circumstances
particularly for the elderly and they're
very young and people's pets as well has
to be said um there's a much much more
vulnerable in these temperatures
um and I think people uh who have family
members in falling into those categories
will be concerned that uh this heat is
only going to be over it's going to be
another 48 Hours 24 48 hours for we get
some reprieve they keep showing pictures
there and there are people enjoying the
enjoying the heat of course as many
people that are doing that as well what
making the most of the the Summer sun
but the infrastructure wise our
government isn't our country isn't
particularly well equipped in the way
that you might see some of our Southern
European neighbors are dealing with
these sorts of temperatures yes I mean
I'm those pictures by by a swimming pool
you know we don't mind these
temperatures when we're if maybe we're
on holiday and we can cool down in the
sea or elsewhere but if you try and go
about your normal business and you know
schools State schools are still open
aren't they um you know kids going in a
mine and PE kit today for example uh
just to try and cool them down and the
eye here Matt saying the Earth is
sending a warning 95 chance that today
will be Britain's hottest on record
um with uh 40 degrees Plus in Sheffield
they say higher than Cairo Tehran New
Delhi Islamabad and Dubai and in recent
years we've seen the heat Dome over
North West of North America over India
you know and experts today saying that
actually the Northern Hemisphere needs
to accept that its climate is is
changing and changing permanently
yeah that's right and what's actually
quite worrying is uh the forecast for
even later this summer so people was
talking about the data the later this
decade but um later this summer the
forecast is saying that so he could
return this kind of level of heat could
return those summer because of the
Sahara and hot air moving northwards
which is causing this heat wave and uh
and as we were talking earlier uh that
every three every three years it's
forecast to reach 40 degrees uh by the
end of the century uh which is quite
remarkable because I mean I've I've been
very bored by my parents talk about the
1976 Heat Wave but and now we're
basically going to be hitting a record
pretty much every other year so it's
going to be
um the norm uh and what's quite
incredible a bit uh touched on the lack
of infrastructure is that a reading
about gritters being sent out and we're
used to that obviously in the winter but
grit has been sent out of this heat wave
but my favorite store my favorite story
I think in the Met uh the Metro sorry uh
was that even pigs were being doused in
suncream at the Royal Welsh show which I
thought was uh quite a lovely little
scene
yeah their skin burns doesn't it I
remember learning that a couple of years
ago in fact we can't escape politics
um you know given what's happening in
the world and there is the guardian
pepper uh Johnson accused of checking
out as Britain swelter's in the Searing
heat uh Missing um a number of Cobra
emergency meetings although we heard Kip
malthouse today saying you know this is
literally my job to coordinate
government departments so should he be
there should he should he not what do
you think
well this is absolutely the case that
Prime Ministers aren't at every Cobra
meeting and nor do they need to be
um but it is particularly striking
because this prime minister has a record
of course of uh of not attending some of
those he should attend you're
remembering a customer went back to this
there's half a dozen or so Copa meetings
at the beginning of the pandemic which
he wasn't at and it does feel that um it
might be if not strictly necessary for
logistical reasons then certainly a good
thing for PR reasons
um on behalf of the the government if
the Prime Minister looks like he was a
bit more involved in response in a
response to the heat wave that as the
Tory leadership contest rumbles on it's
hard to escape the feeling that the Tory
party is kind of focused on this the
infighting and um and sort of internal
issues when it's not just a heat wave of
course but there are all sorts of other
issues ambulance shortages uh which
predates the the current escalation in
the crisis during the heat wave
um cost of living uh situation energy
the crisis partly caused by the
situation abroad which aren't really
getting the sort of looking that you
might want them to and of course Boris
Johnson has been it's been particularly
highlighted over the last couple of days
because
he was at Checkers on Sunday having a
farewell party farewell barbecue with um
his closest colleagues and advisors
and he was last week
um videoed video which I attacked today
uh buying a national NATO fighter jet
um looking like he was having a really
you know great time Top Gun style there
you go those are the pictures thoroughly
enjoying himself he talked about this at
length when he came into the former Air
Show and spoke to Business Leaders and
he spoke about it again in the House of
Commons and confidence votes debate uh
later on as well it obviously has danger
for him is it looks like he's trying to
get through a bucket list of fun
activities before he stands down event
formerly in eight weeks time while at
the same time the Tory party is
distracted by the leadership contest and
the country is facing all of these
issues which just aren't going away
to be fair that's some bucket list isn't
it there's Army there are amazing
pictures and uh surviving a a confidence
vote as well uh as well tonight so we
will see we will move on to what you
talked about there the conservative
leadership campaign something else
hotting up the race to be Boris
Johnson's successor more on that after
this
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
Press preview with me now papakura and
Matt dathan welcome back to both of you
um so let's go to the conservative
leadership contest shall we uh Tom
toucan hat eliminated today uh the
financial times
um has this on the front page down the
bottom there suggesting that Liz truss
uh foreign secretary is was last night
catching up with trade Minister Penny
Morton as they battled to join former
Chancellor Rishi sunak in the final
stages but the times suggests in fact
that the Tory race has been thrown wide
open suggesting that the contest is
expected to culminate in a clash between
mordant and Trust for second place but
their failure to do better could open a
route for kemi badenog now this is
fascinating isn't it whose votes go
where and we really are at crunch Point
Pippa oh
we really are and you know I think
depending on who you speak to and the
conservative party tonight and which
candidate they support you could read
tonight's results uh one of several ways
if you are a Rishi cynic supporter you
have solidified your lead he's only five
votes off now a guaranteed place in the
final runoff looks like a dead start to
be
um on the last two that go around the
country and uh for the Tory members
decide which then becomes prime minister
if you're Penny mordant well you say
that you've your support has held firm
she's put out a new video tonight A much
more personal video than her first one
um still sees herself as um as a front
runner and could potentially pick up
some of the support from Tom tuguna as
the remaining you say slightly liberal
or slightly more liberal than the others
candidates still in the race if you
distrust you put on a few votes you're
catching up with Penny Merchant but
you're not quite there yet so I think
General um generally accepted she did
better in the in the ITV debate on
Sunday night than she did in Channel 4-1
on Friday so possibly put on a little
bit of support but is by no means a dead
start in the second in the second round
of this as well and they came bad enough
snapping at least trust's heels her she
insists that she's in it to win it she's
planning on staying in
um but it I think it is certainly looks
at this point
um as though she's the most likely to go
out next time around but a lot of it
comes down as you say Anna to wear Tom
took anat's foods go he had 31 votes
tonight
um in the in the last latest round of
the tour leadership contest which way do
they break do they break to Penny Warden
as a as a fellow liberal or vulnerable
candidate do they vote to Kimmy badner
if I spoke to one MP earlier who's
previously supported Tom Duggan who said
they backed him because he was the
change candidate well kiwi badenox the
only change candidate left of the race
despite politically been quite different
from um from Tom to gnats so you you can
read this many ways I think you know
we're not there yet to be we're not able
yet to say clearly what's going to
happen I think the one thing we can say
is that over the next 40 times we're
going to continue to see a huge amounts
of Evangeline publicly but possibly more
than that lots of prostrating privately
as well uh perhaps even offers of jobs
as the remaining candidates try and win
more support to get them to move the
line yes private horse trading and
public to uh Penny Warden certainly
tweeting about the need for a clean
start and praising Tom tugenhatt you
know a direct appeal to his uh his USP
on this one and the times uh say they've
done an interview with Liz truss and the
paper says she has issued a direct
appeal to badenock supporters uh saying
that Britain faces a pivotal moment and
must go for growth by cutting taxes
etc etc I mean this really is
fascinating and it feels like um matters
if the as if the contest has followed a
predictable path so far but may not yet
in the last two days what do you reckon
hey
I mean it all could change in the next
three days it's going to be quite a uh
roller coaster of 48 hours ahead and
Wednesday evening we'll finally find out
who are the remaining two this there's
there's voices all over the place um
mixed in with the uh Theresa Mays former
Chief of Staff has made an interesting
point he said the conservatives really
should put a Rishi sunak and Liz trust
through to the final two because they
offer the most opposing uh visions of
Britain Rishi Suna being the fiscally
responsible one and Liz trust being the
uh University cut taxes to fuel growth I
think the total value of a tax cuts are
about 30 billion right now but she's
also in the times interview tomorrow uh
pledge to raise defense spending by
three percent by the end of the decade
which is stealing Tom tugenhart's uh
policy maybe that's a Overture to his 31
supporters
um but we're going to come on I think to
to uh Daily Mail and they make a very
good point we'll crack on with that yeah
gone then modern's number 10 bid hits
the buffers and the the guardian two
trust Camp says backing for mordant has
has peaked continue out here
yeah they make a main point of right at
the end of their front page that there's
just 24 votes separating the three women
I mean I can actually see a pathway for
all three of them to get to the final
two and at the same time we've got
Richard tunak who can basically start
preparing for the next phase which is a
crucial Advantage because I don't know
if they decided yet people might know
but they uh the Tory party last time
sent the ballots out straight away as
soon as the MPS have had their final say
and that meant that people most most
Tory members actually got their voting
straight away so we should soon I can
start planning for that that phase okay
just quickly pepper
I don't know what this I don't know what
they're planning to do but it is postal
votes as Matt said and of course every
day will count when it comes to the
final two that make it through in terms
of winning those up to 200 000 Tory
members and just in a word who's going
to be well if if Rishi is one who would
be who would the other be
oh
you're more dense sorry you're not going
to get me to commit to that and Matt
yeah okay we will see or despite what
the mail said today uh both of you thank
you ever so much we will see you soon
Pippa and Matt thank you